جوله جديده من مفاوضات الحكومه الفنزويليه
واعتلاف المعارضه على وشكل انطلاق في
المكسيك
ستركز الجوله على برنامج المساعدات
الانسانيه لفنزويلا التي تعاني من ظروف
الانسانيه بالغه التعقيد وكذلك على شروط
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرر اجرائها بعد
عامين تقول الحكومه الفنزويليه اين
المفاوضات ستجرى على مستوى جديد وفي نقطه
جديده وانها ستوقع السبت اتفاقا مع
المعارضه سيتيح تحرير موارد فنزويليه
مجمده في الخارج من اجل تمويل مشاريع
اجتماعيه وهو ما شدد عليه المعارضه قائله
ان الاتفاق ذو طابع اجتماعيه ومن شان عوده
الطرفين الى المفاوضات المعلقه منذ اكتوبر
من العام الماضي ان تؤدي الى رفع التجميد
عن مليارين وسبع مئه مليون دولار من
الودائع في الحسابات الدوليه وينتظر
استخدامها باشراف الامم المتحده في تموين
مشاريع تتعلق باعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه
في البدايه
الرئيس الفنزويلي نيكولاسما دورو عدو
الولايات المتحده اللدود استبق المفاوضات
المتوقعه بشكر الوسطاء من النرويج وفرنسا
والمكسيك وركز على ان الاتفاقيه المتوقعه
ستبرم بين الفنز والاليين ومن اجلهم
علينا وضع الامور في مكانها وسائل الاعلام
المهيمنه في الغرب والولايات المتحده
والحكومه الاجنبيه لن تفرض اي شيء على
فنزويلا اليوم ولا في اي وقت على الاطلاق
اسمعوني جيدا لن يفرض علينا احد اي شيء
اليوم وغدا وابدا
زعيم المعارضه البارز الذي يحظى بدعم
الولايات المتحده يقول ان المعارضه تعول
كثيرا على مفاوضات المكسيك ويعتبرها افضل
خيار ويرى ان اي فشل يصاحبها سيزيد الازمه
سوءا وتطالب المعارضه التي تتهم الرئيس
بتزوير انتخابات عام 2018 بجدول زمني
انتخابي جديد ومتفق عليه وعلى مختلف
مستوياته وصولا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقرره عام 2024 مع ضمانات بشان شرعيه
التصويت فضلا عن الافراد عن سجناء
السياسيين